Jamal Murray had the ball at the end of
the first quarter and he started getting
his package and Joker popped open and
Joker like thought he was about to get
the ball for a wide open three and then
he realized Jamal wasn't passing it and
Jamal started dancing to step back the
right play would have been to throw the
ball The Joker and let him shoot him
because he was wide open but Jamal is
also a big shot Taker and a big shot
maker so he wants that moment step back
try to shot the ball and missed it and
what you will see in most situations
they dropped their head they slumped
their shoulders hold their hands like
this right like making it obvious that
they were open Joker clapped his hand
but it was like a clap like ah he barely
missed almost it wasn't like a clap I
should have got the ball shoulders did
not drop a centimeter body language did
not change not one bit
and that's why they're in the NBA final